[Music]
nor money dropped a pop and transported
us straight back to the early 2000s hull
while paying tribute to all the queens
of the era always make a joke saying I
feel like I was born during the wrong
time I was born in 96 so I didn't really
get to enjoy it and experience
everything so I just kind of want to
bring it back and pay tribute Romani
lives out all her childhood dreams in
the music video for her debut solo
single motivation which starts with a
younger version of the star sitting down
to watch a BET's music video countdown
show 106 and park that's when we launch
into all the references to nominees
idols ashy channels Beyonce and crazy
and love era a no 1 2 step J Lo and I'm
real
[Music]
and even Britney Spears in baby one more
time
[Music]
Britney seemingly gets another nod
during a rain themed sequence this does
Beyonce with normani sporting a look
that references the Queens first solo
album cover when they have just been
killing it and on top and it's it's
beautiful to really see especially in a
male-dominated field it is you know I
guess what it is but I mean I think that
we're definitely holding our own and
showing them oh we're made of still no
money didn't forget about the guys in
the video angle Maj - Usher's my way and
omarion's touch motivation is expected
to be the lead single off Norma's highly
anticipated debut solo album which will
hopefully be out before the end of the
year working on the album right now
amazing producers and songwriters just
being in the studio and really excited
to give my fans what it is that they've
been longing for for some time now so
they've been so supportive it's coming I
promise
[Music]